holding a meeting in a walk changes the
dynamic you know if you have a meeting
with someone in an office then you're
sort of there entering the room you're
entering the room with all the sort of
things that have been happening that day
all the sort of dynamics that they bring
to an office setting when you go outside
you're changing it up people who are on
the walk are participating they're not
checking their email they're not
drifting off or looking at other things
they're totally focused on the
conversation there's a great bike path
from our office that goes all the way
into Georgetown there's no cars so
there's no you know even have to worry
about traffic or any other disruptions
some of the more difficult conversations
I've had have happened on blocks and
you're actually not always looking
directly at each other and that may be
helpful when you have to you or the your
person your win has to say maybe
something difficult or even emotional
some of the toughest issues were
grappling with you know if we know we're
near a decision well we may take one
last walk to just talk it through the
pace of walking also brings a different
energy to the conversation